trine est né un quart de siècle après la
loi 100 mais à seulement 18 ans elle à
la défense du français chevillée au
corps
je pense qu'elle est français et c'est
vraiment estimant montréal de la culture
partout on voit dans les commerces dans
les rues on voit qu'elle en une station
prend de plus en plus d'ampleur elle est
inquiète comme beaucoup de montréal et
ils sont 22% à penser que le français
est en recul comme langue de travail
36 % quand on parle de l'accueil dans
les commerces
un exemple la toute première boutique
uniqlo au québec qui a été inauguré en
grande pompe la semaine dernière elle a
essuyé des critiques sur internet
entreprises qui ne respectent pas la
langue française ou encore personnels
unilingue anglophone et uniqlo premier
que 100 % des employés maîtriseront le
français la pénurie de main d'oeuvre a
pu contribuer à abaisser les critères
des entreprises ces dernières années de
ce fait le point intéressant du sondage
les 18 24 ans sont sur la même longueur
d'onde que les 65 ans et plus pour le
constat sur le recul de la langue avec
deux autres jeunes femmes catherine a
lancé une pétition qui a recueilli dix
mille signatures
on veut tailler un conseil de la langue
française pour qu'ils puissent proposer
des mesures plus concrètes à la ville de
montréal
elle espère être entendue par
l'administration
quant aux autres paliers de gouvernement
pour la première fois dans la loi sur
les langues officielles on va
reconnaître que le français est une
langue minoritaire et que dans les
circonstances on doit faire plus pour
protéger le fait français
de son côté québec a octroyé 5 millions
supplémentaires à l'office québécois de
la langue française qui vient notamment
de mettre en garde
cette boulangerie italienne parce
qu'elle affirme vendre des espresso et
des granites à
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal